good afternoon everyone thank you very
much for joining us today uh so we have
the pleasure of having both professor
teresa betancourt who is the salem
professor in global practice at boston
college school of social work
she's also the director of the research
program on children
and um an adversity
and we have one of her collaborators
buhan galtem who is the senior commun
community advisor of the bhutanese
society of western massachusetts and an
fsir community advisor at their
a they're gonna be
talking today uh about the family based
mental health promotion for somali bantu
and bhutanese refugees
the results of a feasibility and
acceptability
trial that they did
thank you so much
teresa and
thank you everyone in the program at
yale for inviting us today it's really
our honor
on this very momentous day
in the history of the united states to
be giving this talk especially to focus
on new americans with a refugee life
experience and our work in
community-based participatory research
to develop an intervention and to share
with you some of our early
findings on feasibility acceptability
and where we hope to go next so
i'm theresa bettencourt and
hi i am buwan gautam and thank you for
the introduction earlier and i also let
you know that i am sharing a lot of my
lived
refugee experiences in addition to our
current research program with children
and adversity with dr bettenberg
thank you bowen it's such an honor to
have you here and to share this platform
with you
uh so i'd like to just give
a little more information
about um
where i'd like to go with the
presentation
um some background on
our research program on children and
adversity and its conceptual drivers and
then buwan's going to talk about the
principles of community-based
participatory research and its use
within two communities the somali bantu
refugee community
starting first in chelsea massachusetts
and then moving out to lewiston maine
and
i'll cover some of that and then
particularly from his lived experience
talking about the bhutanese refugee
experience and then we'll talk about the
intervention that we co-created and our
early findings on feasibility and
acceptability in a recently published
trial in the journal of adolescent
health and then we'll talk a bit about
cobit 19 and how we are iterating and
adapting and using technology as
the team adjusts to this global pandemic
and how to still serve families
in
the community-based participatory
research and intervention study
so as you heard in the introduction i
direct a research program on children
and adversity and in this work our focus
is to really understand
factors and processes that contribute to
risky life outcomes as well as resilient
life outcomes amongst children youth
families
and their broader communities that face
adversity globally
and the focus in this work is not just
on deficits but on strengths and
capacities and in learning about this
sort of information we hope to
contribute to developing an evidence
base that's based on local strengths and
resources and also helps us close this
no do gap that we know a lot about the
science of early adversity and its
impact on child development and mental
health
but we still see very large treatment
gaps in low resource settings both the
united states and around the world and
we need to be doing our highest quality
most efficient and effective work in
those low resource settings to address
racial and ethnic disparities in health
so we have a range of research projects
uh within our lab they sort of fall into
these three broad domains
um first is the global work on war
affected children uh we've had research
projects underway on the ethiopia
eritrea border in the russian federation
with the chechen displacement on child
soldiers in northern uganda and other
internally displaced persons and then
for now 18 years we've been working in
sierra leone west africa
building from an intergenerational study
of war following a cohort of 529 young
people including many former child
soldiers as they become young adults
right now with four waves of data
collection and this has been funded by
the national institutes of child health
and human development
and we now have a 15-year
follow-up of this cohort i'm just
published in jcap
uh which we're very honored to have that
opportunity and then we've been working
on other forms of adversity in rwanda we
started first on the topic of hiv
aids-affected families and in
partnership with the government
as well as the world bank and others
usaid
have moved towards a focus not just
specific to hiv but on children in
extreme poverty and using a family-based
preventative intervention
that's been adapted to focus on early
childhood development and violence
prevention and so we've just published
the pre-post results of a trial a
cluster randomized trial of over a
thousand families in rwanda with the
intervention we call sugar muyongo
and that actually is the same family
strengthening intervention that says at
the base of the um the intervention that
buwan and i will talk about today in our
project on promoting resilience and
healthy parent-child relationships in
new american families the united states
and this work is sponsored by the
national institutes of minority health
and health disparities and we've had an
r24 as well as an r1 and we're going to
share with you the early results from
the r24 and the r01 is underway so go on
i'll turn it over to you
sure thank you dr bettencourt um there
is a background image you can see that
lots of the times when i uh talk
in this kind of forums people ask me
what does the refugee camp hot look like
the house look like and this is what it
looks like looks like in 2015 i went to
a refugee camp in nepal where i became
refugee for 15 and a half years before i
came to this country
and i took this picture which is one of
my friends house and which is really
small and that's really ties into this
largest
humanitarian disaster that's happening
since world war ii and
again that's going in the middle of
pandemic look at these numbers globally
at the end of 2019 there were about 80
million people forcibly displaced
and
if you see the number of children living
in the conflict zone which rose by 74
percent of the last
decade
so
if you think at the united states which
we will talk about i will show you more
data
about how
the resettlement landscape has
changed
and that really needs additional
interventions to address the needs of
the refugee population who comes with
the unique needs
yeah thank
you when we talk about the unique needs
of refugee children and their
development their mental health we have
to go all the way back to yuri bronfman
brenner and think you know
developmentally ecologically we have to
think about the role of time and
maturation so certainly onto genetic or
individual factors matter age gender
temperament intelligence your genetic
history
but we also have to think about what's
going on at the level the family the
nature of caregiver child relationships
family functioning caregiver mental
health resources in the family and then
we can't stop there we also have to
think about the nested and
interrelatedness of the community
ecosystem who else is available in the
life of that young child in terms of
mentors coaches religious figures other
supports extended family peer group
which becomes all the more important
over the process of development and then
as we see in our country today all of
this is
very much nested within the historical
the political the social and the
cultural context and this also relates
to beliefs about reconciliation healing
and moving forward so all of these come
into play when we think about any one
child's outcomes
we won
so
if we look at the
refugee resettlement trajectory as
compared to last year
use um not last year before the current
administration we used to have 70 000
refugees each year that's what the us
government has the highest ceiling had
the highest ceiling but after the trump
administration took office it was
drastically reduced down
and if you look at the fiscal year 2021
which is 15 000 refugees and that's the
maximum ceiling and then when you when
you have people in the pipeline and then
they end up coming less than the actual
uh ceiling uh limit set
and uh today's election is going to
decide what direction the refugee
resettlement will uh take uh which will
uh we will hopefully see a change in
this but
let's see wait and see
um as i was mentioning before a person
who was very young i i left um country
when i was i became a refugee when i was
seven years old and having to spend a
lot of time my
childhood and then adulthood in a
refugee camp
i was exposed to a different factors
that increased the risk of poor mental
health and health outcomes and i'm
coming to the united states along with
100 000 other folks like me and not only
bhutanese but there are millions of
other refugees and immigrants coming
with these different forms of hardships
they have um
with them so the data uh shows that
children in the us have a very poor
access to mental health services and
situation has increased
in refugees from the data we have found
thank you everyone and
also when our refugees come to this
country they have many barriers as
compared to the u.s
population
for example refugee folks are really
reluctant to uh rece seek out services
because of the stigma
in mental health and also there is
because of the language barriers and
cultural differences there is lack of
resources
in the areas they live
and most families are overwhelmed by
their own migration experiences
similarly services access is very poor
especially for children and families may
not be able to recognize their own needs
i mean
to be
to to not to have a clinical access or
mental health access is what they had in
their camp and when when you come from a
place like refugee camp
sometime um being a refugee you don't
even know what resource exists and i and
sometimes our parents even may not be
able to recognize their own needs
and they are unaware about the services
as um the refugee and immigrant folks
are
they do not have a
high
literacy rate and the resources are so
low
and also because of so many other
barriers they are there are limited to
referral networks from school and
pediatric
etc to address the needs of our refugee
children
um so when you see at the trajectory of
the ref um uh stages of the displacement
when somebody becomes a refugee
and then they go through different
stages of life for example pre-flight uh
someone had for example i put i can put
myself into this
stage that i was
in bhutan as i mentioned i was very
young i had to leave i was the first
grader actually
and um
i was exposed to the violence and i had
many other forms of traumatic
experiences and when when i be when i
came to the united states as i mentioned
in 2008 i
i was
again it was a new journey for me along
with my family to go to the place that
they don't even know it's like an
unknown destination even if they said
united states that
means it was completely a foreign land
uh my both of my parents are illiterate
in their own language and imagine about
leaving a country and going to a place
that they don't actually know what's
going to happen
and other uh resettlement also brings
migration laws and acculturation issues
it's a lot when someone is
someone has to go
and learn the new language and adapt to
a mainstream culture and along with the
financial hardships but also to let you
know that there are protective factors
that um refugee
families bring
which are uh
really uh
great in terms of building uh together
as a as a
resiliency factors from individual to
family
to access to education and
communities
ideological and religious context i mean
we refugee communities are coming from a
low resource um settings and then having
to go um and reintegrate and then
accurate in with the mainstream society
sometimes requires a lot of efforts and
i think this kind of collaboration and
the partnership has really helped us to
move forward and with these positive
protective factors researchers really
have to put this together to build the
intervention that works for refugees
can i please ask a question
sure
yeah
like i so i had the impression that
bhutan is a very peaceful country so i
am kind of completely at loss
that there are refuses from bhutan uh to
the us so if you could please uh share
the perspective like what what led you
to become a refugee
i'm glad that you asked this question
thank you so much i know that bhutan has
been
bhutan
says that it's the happiest country on
the world which you which my you might
have heard that's right
this gross national happiness right
but that's the other side of the story
now the met the truth of the matter is
that bhutan has forcibly evicted over
one hundred thousand nepali speaking
southern bhutanese uh from its country
in nineteen early eighteen nineteen
eighties to nineties which i was gonna
talk but that's great then i can escape
later um
and i am one of those people forcibly
evicted and became refugees and if you
see that's one of the reason
that
we partner with
boston college and harvard school of
public health to
to
basically to heal the mental health
problem the torture mental health
problem that bhutan had created so that
our families could be helped we have
lots of people um who are the victims of
the torture from by the buddhist
authority bhutanese police we still have
families in
separated in bhutan who are not able to
join our families they are in jail there
is a horrible other part of the story
which i would encourage you to look into
it and you will have a deeper
understanding about the
plight of the bhutanese refugees okay
thank you
and we can connect yeah sorry go ahead
now i have a follow-up question about
this so i was reading a little bit about
the situation in bhutan and the kind of
policies that they implement in schools
it seems that they socialize children
since a very early age and the way they
communicate with the children and they
convey the importance of being happy i
guess it i i was wondering how does that
affect your measurement of welding your
measurement of depression for instance
which is so so susceptible to how you
think about your emotional states and
do you think this poses an additional
challenge for measuring depression do
you think that biomarkers might be
particularly uh necessary in the case of
bhutanese refugees how do you think
about that well um to
tell you the truth that when i became
refugee i as i mentioned that i was very
young and uh
well i really started to understand the
complexity of this issue when i became
adult in a refugee camp in nepal and i
further understood about my own rights
um about
not being able to
practice my fundamental rights is
something that i'm experiencing and i'm
really
whenever i go to the platform i i talk
about these issues when some of someone
comes up who have never heard about the
other side of the story but to go with
the flow of
this uh presentation we have a lot to
cover and dr bettencourt and i are
really uh initially were talking that we
might have to answer some of the
questions when you have something coming
up in your mind please continue to jot
down your questions and we will have the
question and answer session to
go through them to cover the whole
presentation yeah thanks
i think the question um
is an important one a little bit about
some of the form of work that we did
to make sure that our measures were fit
to context and reflected um sort of
cultural uh culturally appropriate
language that is used by locals who may
not have had the opportunity to you know
receive much education and may not be
literate but really doing a lot of
formative work in a community-based
participatory research
framing
to
learn those terms and make sure that we
weren't using stigmatizing terms and
then the collection of biological data
biomarkers is an objective
indicator is also very interesting
something we can talk about i think in
the discussion a bit more because there
are ethical issues also involved in that
trust and relationship and communities
as you know
so let me talk a little bit now about
just the co-creation process of
intervention development in
collaboration with refugee communities
using community-based participatory
research
and buwan do you want to talk about some
of our different partners you know i
want to talk a little bit of the history
of the project and accolades different
partners involved with dr bettencourt
and i are
having the opportunity to speak with you
right now but as you can see in the list
we have several others
for example we have um
i mean uh we have in maine immigrant
refugee services and jewish family
services of western massachusetts
and uh early partnership that began even
before i um i joined dr bettencourt with
chelsea collaboratives and uh
and react and other academic
collaborators both at uh harvard and uh
uni harvard university and university of
michigan
and
boston children's hospital and our
funding support from national institute
of minority health and health dispar
disparity
and community consultants we have um
collaborators that are really helping us
to develop this uh
whole research and intervention project
so that leads to uh
real nice definition from kellogg
foundation
community based participatory
research cbpr
is a collaborative approach to
research that equitably involves all the
partners in the research process and
recognized
recognizes the unique strengths
that each bring cbpr brings
begins with a research topic of
importance to the community
has the aim of combining knowledge with
action and achieving social change to
improve health outcome and eliminate
health disparities
so
again it's
the cbpr engages
researchers and community members like
me
to
equitable partnership
to deconstruct the power differential um
and also
community members are engaged in all the
processes
um let me give you some of the features
of the cbpr because this is the process
of power sharing as
the
we come up with the challenges and
to address that we we
focus on the strengths to offset the
weaknesses and community members are
engaged in each step of the research
process so cbpr is especially especially
helpful when working with a
stigmatized community
or with this stigmatized topic because
it allows you to be you to gain deeper
insights and
lead enhance understanding
that creates a deeper buy-in and
motivation
necessary
to encounter stigma so the advantages
are to increase
the knowledge and to build the bridges
and enhances the research process
so
uh it might take a lot um time and uh
resource to prepare uh to develop the
partnership but at the end of the day we
are thinking of building the social
capital uh
uh strength in those low resource
setting communities
um as i can emphasize that
there is a limited implication so far in
mental health and this is uh we are so
glad that we are sharing um our work
with you all
uh cbpr has promising risk approach uh
given the stigma
around mental health
and it's really important to understand
the local context and language um around
the mental health problem that can
improve
the community engagement and
inform the intervention
so our cbpr approach is by refugees for
refugees we have unique approach
uh we have two cab uh community board
advisory boards uh one is
youth cab we call youthcap and in youth
camp we have middle schoolers and high
schoolers
um
that because the research program is for
the children um and the parents we would
like we are we continue to seek advice
from those children's point of view also
and uh from the parents who are the cab
members adult cab members
uh sharing their feedback to the
research which will help us to document
their feed
and which will help us to document their
feedback
and
we would develop culturally and
linguistically
appropriate intervention in our fsi
module
so community outreach
events we have we try to
spread the work that we do as much as
possible not leaving anyone in the
community
and
also we have monthly meetings and uh and
i am one of the liaison with the
boston school um
social uh school of social work with dr
bettencourt and our job and uh not only
me i have other colleagues who are not
here
would our job is to advise on our
cultural and
social and cultural needs
great so
i'll give a little background on the
somali bantu refugee community and then
turn it over for um we want to give a
little more of the history of the
bhutanese displacement
so the somali bantu refugee community is
actually a subset of the overall somali
displacement
and resettlement
around the world the somali bantu
peoples were originally generations ago
taken from other parts of africa and
served as slaves in somalia uh when the
war broke out in 1991
they were displaced along with the
broader somali majority and to refugee
camps originally and then also resettled
although the early displacement
were from somali majority families who
had access to education and connections
but
there was a decision of the obama
administration to take a large number of
somali bantu as well
but their trauma history is quite high
as you might imagine um very little
access to school historically
prolonged
trauma exposure both just within their
families as well as in the refugee camps
um dadaab and kakuma refugee camps in
kenya
and have had very little access to
education um so a lot of the women the
mothers we work with may not have
literacy in my mind it's mainly a spoken
language uh and so english as a second
language or english language learning
has been very complicated and we'll see
situations where children are learning
english but especially the mothers
haven't had the the basics to allow them
to have a platform to succeed in those
sorts of training programs we need a
different type of literacy education
um and integrated approaches uh overall
somalis are the largest single group of
resettled african refugees in u.s
history um and then the somali bantu are
a subset within this in 2004 over 13 000
somali bantu were resettled in 50
communities across 38 states united
states
so in boston resettlement began the
boston area in 2004 with two families
and soon expanded to over 400 and then
there was secondary migration um to
states where jobs were more plentiful
where housing was more affordable
including to maine and lewiston maine um
being a very large population of both
somali majority and somali bantu
refugees and there have been historical
tensions but also a lot of shared
culture history experience between the
two communities and many of our partners
are coming from both sides you know this
project's mainly been done with the
smelly bantu um because of the language
and the cultural differences but some of
our greatest collaborators are also a
somali majority who are trusted by the
community work very closely with them
over to you buwan
so i'm gonna provide a background of
bhutan bhutan
is a tiny himalayan country between
sandwich between india and china which
is really isolated kingdom of about
seven hundred thousand populism
uh and as i was uh speaking before uh we
have we bhutan government um evicted its
citizen
uh by adopting ethnic cleansing policy
um in early 1990s
uh evicting 100 000 epic nepalese we
call lotsampa that we speak
nepali language in bhutan
under one nation one people policy which
is also known as bhutanization that
targeted cultural and religious and
tradition majority were hindus but also
we have buddhists and christians as well
who be who were evicted
and also our parents citizenship rights
were eliminated
and we all were forced to leave
to neighboring countries and we had to
cross india to get to bhutan and i
remember following the footsteps of my
parents i was young but then i remember
sleeping on the woods it took so many
days to get there in refugee camp
nepal
and in a refugee camp we were settled
this is one of the pictures that i was
talking about in this kind of setting
for 15 and a half years there was no
bathroom not toilet inside it's it's
there is a lot of public health problem
which i am able to recognize that
but again we got we got survived and i'm
here and we that's why it's really
important to
um
deal with the uh hardships and problems
that refugees uh bring uh to address in
us culturally and linguistically and
appropriate way
and
many escape the violence and at the time
i became refugee um when i was
in high school there were there was a
civil war in nepal that had affected
many of um children in nepal as well
and uh diffic there was really a
difficulty not even difficult i mean
more than difficulty uh refugees are not
allowed to go
outside their refugee camps to school
the maximum you could go i could go in
my refugee camp was great 10th grade
and you're done
no education after that employment
forget about it there is no employment
you have to
survive your life on the basic food
dressing provided by you and it's here
and there was a discrimination from the
local nepalese
one i have a question
yes
what was the relationship like like
before uh nepalese uh
bhutanese were uh driven out like was
the relationship very complementary or
like what it's just i'm i'm still in
shock that i had i had i had not
expected that at all from bhutan sure i
mean uh the bhutan
it is a monarchical system of government
there is a king and prime minister
and
bhutan had no problem before 1980s but
after that
when the bhutanese people nepali
speaking people became educated and they
started demanding about the fundamental
rights
and it became a problem
that the community became target and
also the other socio-political
influences nepal was going through uh
political reforms as well as in india
and all kind of uh neighboring
influences uh geopolitical issues might
be okay okay okay thank you
and and buwan's written some very
important commentaries we can share with
the group and there have been these
events in new england around you know
bhutan the happiest kingdom on earth and
not recognizing this truth of their
history you know it's much more complex
than that
yeah
so
there is increased mental health
problems um when refugees they come to
this country due to the resettlement
stressors including cultural adaptation
language and overwhelming information
anxiety which is likely to remain for
prolonged period of time
and the fear for future resettlement in
crime affected areas
and also refugees need to compete in the
job market all of a sudden after
20 years of jobless life which is not
easy
um and as you see in a bhutanese
refugees context in the u.s
thought country resettlement began in
2007 and i was the
first person to come in uh springfield
massachusetts before that i had no idea
about
what massachusetts was in fact i was
told you are going to windsor locks what
is windsor locks i i didn't even have
internet to look up windsor locks and in
fact i found that it was the place um
where the airport bradley
internationally airport was
so
there and after people think that when
refugees are brought to uh to america
the problem is solved now there is a lot
of complexities
um and uh after bhutanese refugees came
to the u.s um cdc published a report
that the suicide rate among the
bhutanese refugees was
um almost three times um more than the
national level right
yeah two times times as high yeah very
alarming rate of suicide around the
united states yes
so
uh thank you bhuan very important
history and also justifies why mental
health was of interest when we invited
the bhutanese to join our partnership uh
and the partnership had started back in
2004 first with the somali bantu in the
boston area and so at that time i was
working at boston medical center with
heidi ellis and others at the refugee
center for trauma and resilience
and we had been contacted by
the lynn public schools in massachusetts
because they'd had a large influx of
somali bantu children
into their classrooms and there were
behavioral problems arising
especially in the younger grades when
teachers would ask things like time to
line up
eyes
and the smelly band kids come pushing
and shoving to the front of the line
and the teachers felt you know that this
was bad behavior but these were kids who
back in the refugee camps those had been
really important survival behaviors if
um food was being distributed you did
need to push to the front of the line
and so there was just a misunderstanding
between the two contacts the teachers
weren't understanding the children and
the families and the parents themselves
didn't really understand how to navigate
the schools so
in somalia it's respectful to turn your
child over um to the mentorship of the
teacher and to not get in the teacher's
hair so they weren't you know coming to
parent-teacher meetings or coming to the
school and getting to know the school
community and the school saw that as
them being disengaged but really they
were trying to be respectful so there
was a big disconnect happening and we
were asked to come in and do some
awareness raising which we did with the
administration and the teachers and also
the community and at that time i met a
ways hussein who was serving as a school
liaison he himself was somali bantu he's
now gone on to finish finish his nursing
degree and he's an amazing person and he
helped us kick off this project we wrote
some early planning grants together and
building this community partnership as
you can see has taken time um to get to
this place of having nih funding but it
started with this collaboration um to
meet both community and research goals
because we were interested in risk and
resilience and more affected children
including um those who come and resettle
the united states and with their
families so here's a picture of a waste
you see him down on the second row in
the middle um at the chelsea collab and
the chelsea collaborative
is an amazing place chelsea's the city
across the river from boston it's a
largely migrant very diverse community
it's been hard hit by covid19 actually a
lot of frontline workers a lot of people
living in crowded housing
um with food insecurity and this
wonderful group the chelsea
collaborative was mentoring
the somali bantu community association
to become their own mutual assistance
organization and um to learn leadership
skills how to write grants how to plan
uh which was really fabulous we'd go in
and we'd speak spanish first and then
we'd be switching to maimai and that's
really how this project started um with
that leadership
uh training of the chamber association
and the partnership with the waste
hussein and so the early aim of the
partnership was to try to understand the
community situation and its priorities
especially related to these issues of
emotional behavioral health and
well-being of children and bringing up
their human capital and ensuring that
they could thrive uh so understanding
the nature of the problems
and its causes as well as what are the
strengths we can leverage before we ever
move to solutions and this meant we had
to improve communication because there's
such issues around stigma and so if we
want to talk about mental health how do
we start so we started
using methods we had used in sub-saharan
africa in northern uganda and rwanda
using first free listing and then moving
to key informant interviews and getting
local syndrome term cover terms that
were non-stigmatizing for a range of
different expressions of emotional
behavioral problems in children and then
using this information to assist in
planning intervention models because we
could talk about strengths uh blue and
do you wanna talk about our partnership
as i mentioned before that we have a
multi-sectoral and multi-disciplinary
team members involved in this project
that includes academic partners refugee
community resettlement agencies
which will guide the study intervention
in study inter investigators in creating
the shared vision through this
collaborative research so our cbpr team
and the community stakeholders really
foster cross-cultural collaboration
in order to drive research questions
which will help us
in the delivery of the improved services
thank you
so
our partnership
we have values and our values are really
invested in the refugee communities
this fits in uh saying um
that um
give mana fees you will eat for a day
teach him how to feast he will eat for
his life right
um
by training the refugee folks what you
will be able to prepare them for
employment in an effort to skill
building in a
low resources communities like
one of them is bhutanese refugee
community
and after the research project is over
the refugee communities will have
produced
the experts who will influence and
inspire others to go for
public health schools and also address
some of the health and public health
problems that we had never known before
i mean
i came to this country in 2008 and
worked at the resettlement
agencies for five and a half years
till then i had no idea about public
health issues uh i mean before i got
involved with the research institutions
and um
uh
community health center it's a lot when
a refugee community member is involved
and trained in this type of work so
um
in a collectivist society
like bhutanese community these skills
will build social capital resources
which can be used by
not just the springfield bhutanese
communities but the bhutanese diaspora
and
so now i'm going to talk a little bit
about mixed methods and how we approach
this work
so
this quote from arthur kleinman who's a
very well-known medical anthropologist
and psychiatrist at harvard captures
what we're up against when we think
about culture and there was an earlier
question about assessment
uh as well as then you know what you
learn locally to think about
intervention development so as climate
states we know from ethnography
convincingly that concepts of emotions
the self and the body and general
illness categories differ so
significantly in different cultures that
it can be said that each culture's
beliefs about normal and abnormal
behavior are actually quite distinctive
so that's where we run into problems if
we just assume that tools we use um with
you know americans or in western
populations can just be given a forward
translation and now they're going to
work with bhutanese refugees or somali
bantu refugees uh so we really try to go
about this approach in a very different
way starting um with the emic
perspective locally uh in qualitative
formitative work uh formative work to
understand local constructs related to
mental health to parent-child
relationships and parenting to
protective processes that are relevant
to better outcomes for um children and
families that face challenges and then
to use that data to select our measures
adapt standard measures or where there
isn't a good alignment create new
measures and and test them through
validity studies and we also now we're
learning not just about the problems but
about the protective resources so the
ingredients for potential intervention
models uh that can help promote better
outcomes and so that's coming into this
phase where we're informing the
intervention model selecting the
intervention model based on that
formative work thinking about fit to
context and evaluate these
interventions using the most rigorous
designs possible including randomized
control trials and now in a lot of our
work in different parts of sub-saharan
africa and even now the second stage r01
of this project
looking at implementation science
questions so hybrid designs where we're
looking at effectiveness but also
testing strategies for quality
improvement fidelity monitoring
and scaling out
so
we talked a little bit about some of the
formative work if you're interested
there's a really tremendous amount of
detail in this paper we published back
in 2015 in the american journal of
public health and this represented our
community-based participatory research
in the two communities and how we got at
those local uh terms we're talking in a
non-stigmatizing way about mental health
and based on that we also
did work on the protective resources
and
this work got some really wonderful
attention we made the cover of the
harvard magazine back when i was at
harvard for many years
uh
before i um professorship at boston
college and also we were able to have
our refugee team come and help us
disseminate the results the early
formative work and what we were learning
about youth issues at chelsea city hall
um with policy makers uh and leaders
there in the community
and so now i want to talk about moving
from that data to intervention
co-creation and code development and
talk about the family strengthening
intervention
some of you may know the work of dr
william beardsley
who his original intervention was
developed for the prevention of
depression and the offspring of
depressed caregivers
after the formative work and after
looking at different intervention models
that could be done by lay people
that were strength-based that really
had a focus on families and their
functioning as a way of promoting
well-being in the children we saw a
tremendous alignment and opportunity
with bill's model
we had been working with bill in rwanda
on adapting this for hiv affected
families and then we had this aha moment
of goodness this is working in
sub-saharan africa we're working with
somali bantu refugees back in the boston
area
maybe this could also work well with the
diaspora resettling new americans and
the refugees
back in new england and so that was the
initial idea and we saw this as an
exciting opportunity to think about
making it a fit to this setting in the
context of
refugee families are settled in the
united states um so the conceptual model
and i what i also want to mention when
it comes to implementation science is
that bill's family talk intervention is
um registered in the national registry
of effective programs and practices so
it has a pretty broad evidence base and
in rwanda we adapted it more broadly not
just to depression but to other mental
health problems in children and that was
sort of the idea here too because
um distressed refugee children doesn't
only present in the form of depression
although you know it can also show up in
conduct problems anxiety um so we wanted
to think broadly about mental health and
promoting mental health and so the
conceptual model here is we're working
with refugee families that have this
history of past trauma as well as the
resettlement and the culturative
stressors that you heard about from buon
some of the risk factors that we learn
about in our formative work were just
limited access to services not even you
know knowing much about mental health or
understanding um how to navigate and get
help for the family get help for
children lots of misunderstandings as
you heard about the us education system
also social services we can tell you all
sorts of stories about misunderstanding
about child protective services or 9-1-1
and all those interactions and a lot of
fear
and then just communication breakdowns
as i mentioned oftentimes you'll have
children who are
quickly learning english learning
because they're growing up in u.s
culture and then you've got a mother and
parents who are coming from a very
different background and may not even
have the ability um to speak in the same
language in the same household
and so of course as you might imagine we
have issues of intergenerational
conflict um you know where there's a lot
of tension um and poor communication
between
children and their caregivers and so the
core intervention components building
out on bill's model were first this
navigation rule because this is done by
refugees for refugees with home visitors
being from the community they can help
them navigate both the formal systems
like understanding the educational
system
child protective services medical care
insurance but also informal supports
like getting additional supports from
friends from neighbors from community
associations and as you heard in the
protective processes
those are those mutual assistance
organizations are so critical and the
community trusts and community leaders
like buan are so critical uh and then a
lot of work on just understanding the us
education system and we've been focused
really on school these children in this
phase of the intervention although um we
do want to eventually work towards early
childhood development as a target
and a lovely part of bill's um model
which
has a nice fit for trauma affected
populations is the family narrative and
this is a chance for the family to tell
the story of their
experience as a family at their own pace
with their own content and it's not
meant to focus on retelling past
traumatic events but really to focus on
the strengths along the way in the in
the joys as well as the difficult events
um what helped you make it through that
time and then where did you come from
what have you been through and where are
you going to look towards the future and
a hope for the future which is so
critical to help refugee families thrive
and then also just developing positive
parenting skills
thinking about routines thinking about
improving communication thinking about
natural consequences spending time
together that's productive and positive
those are all a part of additional
supports that parents are getting and
with the intention being to improve the
parent-child relationship but also
diminish risk of mental health problems
in children which we know are elevated
in refugee children so as you've heard
it's a strengths-based model it was
meant to be brief um can be done by lay
workers it's prevention we're not doing
in-depth treatment
and the idea here is to recognize and
build on existing family strengths to
enhance
resilience and to use those protective
resources as the active ingredients in
promoting mental health and children and
so it follows a manualized protocol we
have weekly meetings between the family
and the home visitor who's from the
community speaks their language knows
their culture and we have separate
sessions for children and adults the
early sessions are really at
understanding
that particular family and its unique
challenges and strengths and then
telling that family narrative from the
perspective of the caregivers but also
then from the perspective of the
children
and then moving through the different
skills and bringing it all together with
a family meeting which is also a very
critical component of bill's
intervention and these family meetings
are something that families may go on to
do after the brief preventative
intervention
so we're going to share with you some
initial results
from the nimhd funded uh
r24 which was a pilot grant to really
look at feasibility acceptability it's
underpowered to get huge statistical
results we're in that trial now but the
intention was to enroll 80 families 40
from each community have pre and post
assessment and have a randomization um
where there there are good usual care
services in these communities and so
just like a lottery some families in
addition to usual care would get the
home visitor
and then all along the way you heard
from buwan about the importance of our
community advisory board so whenever we
had hit snags or needed input especially
in the intervention development but also
as we went giving updates and getting
feedback from the community advisory
boards
in a cbpr manner and documenting that in
a process evaluation as we go
and this is all guided by an
implementation science science framework
that we call epis that really looks at
these different phases of exploration
preparation for the intervention actual
studying of the implementation
and then questions towards in
sustainment and thinking about these
bridging factors between the community
um between the actual features the inner
context of the intervention how hard it
is to do the materials we use making it
more easy to use and the outer context
the funding the policy context and all
of that's ever changing
uh so
in the data i'll show you today the main
research questions were understanding
one i'm going to show you the qual data
and then a little bit of the quant data
and we also are working on a mixed
method paper now where we synthesize
those but the questions were how
acceptable and feasible is the family
strengthening intervention for refugee
families or fsir
and what contributes to that what kind
of changes if any do caregivers and
children observe in themselves and their
families from the intervention
participation and what perspectives do
they have for improving this
intervention
and so i'll show you data that comes
from 36 exit interviews with caregivers
and with children
that looked at those research questions
these were double coded and analyzed
using both grounded theory techniques
but also thematic content analysis
because we have some theory driven codes
uh and so our sample is half and half
somali bantu in bhutanese 10 families um
from the small band 2 side 11 bhutanese
families
and the main themes when it comes to
acceptability and feasibility of doing
this intervention we're really about as
you might imagine just scheduling as a
barrier and overcoming that but also
experiences with discussing the past and
i mentioned that in the conceptual model
and the relationship with the
interventionist and so as you might
imagine these are families that are
working many jobs oftentimes their large
families scheduling issues could be a
barrier
but home visiting really helps us get
far with that when there was a once a
center-based attempt at this
intervention that really failed because
of low participation rates
and the participants shared that
intervention as problem solving them was
such an important part of making it
feasible um so as this mother explains
they would call me beforehand make sure
i was available and i'd tell them to
come over if i was home and we have to
do a lot of double and triple checking
um the somali bantu mother talks about
the patience of the interventionist how
sometimes they'd argue and he would
tolerate them and also was very flexible
about having to reschedule
the bhutanese father here found it was
easy and flexible
um experiences discussed in the past as
i mentioned is a trauma-informed
intervention uh this family narrative
meant that this was an opportunity for
individuals to learn about the family
history um and even
for children for the first time to hear
about the history of their family and
how they come to united states but
sometimes for parents who'd been through
difficult trauma in the past just going
back to any memory of the past could be
triggering or difficult and so we have
to do a lot of training with our
interventionists to you know focusing on
the strengths focusing on the journey
forward and that they're here today and
they're safe and what's the future that
they look for together and so here's the
somali girl saying my favorite part was
when we talked about my grandparents and
stuff my mom never talked about them
before and i liked knowing about them or
the somali mother most of the
intervention was fine but the only thing
i'd say i didn't feel comfortable was
talking about what happened in the past
in somalia and in the refugee camp life
wasn't easy for me and my family
here's a bhutanese boy who said the
interventionist asked us about family
what happened in the past all of that
felt i felt good about he asked about my
birthplace and everything after that i
had forgotten a lot of things um i got
to know things i didn't know because of
him
and so when it comes to the relationship
with the interventionists participants
spoke very highly of having someone from
the community describing them as
respectful patient understanding and
seeing them as a real source of
knowledge
and so the fact that they were part of
the community really contributed to the
acceptability of the intervention so
here's a smally bantu mother i think the
interventionists did a good job i can't
see how anyone else in the community
would be able to do that it was very
helpful to see someone from the
community working in the project and we
understand each other um here's a smelly
bantu mother also the intervention is to
someone who understands the dynamic and
the function of the intervention and the
somali bantu culture
so when talking about the impact on
participants primary themes that emerge
relate to improving communication
more positive time spent together as a
family and also the relationship between
caregivers as well as the relationship
between children and caregivers and so
um for family communication we see that
especially for bhutanese families they
talked about how the intervention led
children to share more with their
parents and vice versa parents took more
initiative to talk with their children
about their lives and for many somali
bantu participants they talked about the
increased time together discussion time
as a family but language barriers still
continue to hinder family communication
so here's a bhutanese mother i learned
that we should not avoid children we
used to do things in certain ways
because we didn't understand but now we
understand that we should talk to each
other and ask about how the other person
is doing who he's with where he's going
when i said he could talk about these
things with his mother we still share
things between mother and son and now we
know things happening in each other's
lives um or here's a somali bantu girl
just to talk with my family was the best
i never talk with my parents like that
and sometimes culturally and especially
we see this in sub-saharan africa
it's not typical that you would speak
directly to your parents about your life
and if you had problems you might go
through an intermediary and we still
respect a lot of those approaches when
we help families problem solve when
they're facing challenges
but also just opening up communication
channels has been a huge part of the
intervention i'm spending time together
they talked about enjoying time together
this bhutanese mother i didn't know how
to give time to children at home i liked
that we learned a lot um we got to give
them time i learned this should have
been like this for generations or the
somali bantu mother another one the
intervention affected family
relationships in a good way none of my
children used to talk before now we
sometimes sit and watch tv together i
always remind them about the
interventionists and what he told them
um here's a bhutanese girl a 12 year old
the thing that was really helpful for
our family is to go to different places
to make plans now this is pre-coped but
there are still ways we're helping
families think about
making there be
really pleasant time together shared as
a family she talked about you know
wanting
talking about very simple outings um to
a park a theme park a water park they
felt closer
and she said before this my mom and dad
had a really busy schedule they made
more time for us so we had more time to
go out and be a family
relationships between caregivers um so
it's different between these two
communities but again it's a small
sample a lot of somali bantu mentioned
the intervention um very few talked
about it really changing the caregiver
relationship the bhutanese stated how
their relationships had been positive
but children really did observe changes
between the caregivers um here's a
smelly bantu mother i love my husband
was it supposed to change um here's a
bhutanese boy who said what he observed
was well before my dad just came back
from work slept said nothing to my
mother now he comes back from work and
actually sits down and talks to my
mother how her day was they talked to
each other i think they found a better
relationship when they took part in the
intervention i think they understand
they like each other more
so when it comes to improving the
intervention the kind of feedback
that they gave were one about seeking
tangible skills which you can imagine a
literacy jobs these things still really
matter and also moving from a family
focus also to think about how can there
be more leverage of the strengths in the
communities
um so seeking tangible skills
even though the intervention was doing
really exciting things on the family
dynamics they talked about so many other
services they need and you see this from
a smally bantu mother i think you need
to start services for the people like
english classes parenting classes youth
group for both boys and girls parent
groups money saving
um here's a bhutanese father talking
about disability which was pretty high
within the bhutanese community and
remains to be a dynamic of the resettled
populations we're working with
and also alcohol abuse be another
important topic
whether connecting them to the services
or some financial assistance or
education and transporting them
those are all things that bhutanese
parents were feeling they still needed
attention to here's a bhutanese boy my
mom and dad can't speak english if they
need to go to hospital you need to be
able to speak english so to help our
parents that with their english that
would help us a lot
um and then we saw this dynamic
especially coming from the youth to talk
about how can we also do things at the
community level so here's a bhutanese
girl if there was a hall for children to
come together to play dance talk learn
nepali language and culture we can't
afford that for our kids or this young
boy services like youth groups or
women's groups or men's groups or
couples groups to bring the community
together at least once a month or twice
would be great and that's why our
community meetings are oftentimes an
event with food we've had cultural
events together and that's why working
with community leaders like buon is so
important for hearing this kind of
feedback and for them to think about
what they can do with those requests
from the community when it comes to the
quantitative results and these are just
published in the journal of adolescent
health if you're interested um with this
pre to post data collection we did see
in the children uh a significant
reduction in those getting the
intervention in their reports of
traumatic stress reactions we also saw
from caregiver reports fewer child
depression symptoms reported by
caregivers um for both communities and
then conduct problems coming both ways
for the bhutanese we saw a significant
reduction in this small sample in
conduct problems but for the somali
bantu we actually saw that it looked
higher in the intervention group so some
of that could be due to variability in
small samples
but definitely the general trend is
there are
exciting
shifts in child mental health in the
small sample we also saw in the
bhutanese side of the equation a report
in reductions in family arguing and when
it came to feasibility and acceptability
for both communities extremely high on
reports of feasibility and also high
reports of satisfaction and
acceptability
and so future steps and i want to make
sure that we have a little time to talk
about covid as you might imagine and as
um buwan mentioned um at our
introduction the policy and the
political landscape are ever shifting if
you can imagine what this project has
seen in the years that started from 2004
2005 to 2020 a lot of shifts in policy
funding resettlement dynamics
when we originally developed this being
done by community lay workers or
community health worker provisions
within the affordable care act and also
provisions for prevention services were
really a big part of our vision for how
we might have this scalable and
reimbursable should it be evidence-based
should it continue to show
an evidence base and that's meant we had
to really focus on state level policies
in massachusetts and maine around
prevention services and what's
reimbursable and who the delivery agents
can be including lay workers and we need
more on is it truly effective and that's
why we're finishing now a well-powered
effectiveness study as well as the
process evaluation steps we've talked
about so buan i'll turn it back to you
to talk about covet 19.
theresa can i can can i ask a couple of
questions so or should i shall we wait
to the end
uh you can ask them now is that
great
but i am happy either way if you want to
if uh
well we're almost done let's finish
these last slides and then we'll just
open it up
okay
due to the covet um you know it's really
challenging before kobe we used to
collect our data uh in person now with
the kovit we are collecting data
remotely
and uh our bilingual bicultural nepali
speaking trained family strengthening
intervention staff
they are the ones who do the data
collection
besides the intervention work
at the request of the communities we
have supported in providing vitally
important public health information
especially around
debunking some of the myths like eating
ginger garlic or steamed mix would one
of the virus
we were able to uh bring
epidemiologists and researchers and
conducted
those information sessions and outlets
and provided education via facebook live
with live interpretations
for our bhutanese populism
and our upcoming one is about supporting
the students and families in the
bhutanese community with remote learning
during this kobe 19 parents are
frustrated children are everywhere it's
a mess
when um especially in our community
where parents don't know what's
happening
um and with that i would like to turn it
over dr bettencourt to talk about
digital
manual and sure thanks bowen and just on
the smallie bantu side uh it's
interesting just there are user
preferences and differences so facebook
live makes sense for the bhutanese but
for the somali band 2 they don't use
facebook live and so to reach those
communities we're working with the local
community leaders using whatsapp groups
um they do a lot of psychoeducation out
of their center where they're still in a
socially distant way wearing mass
holding some sessions on education for
families so it's all about working with
the community and understanding um their
dynamic their needs their preferences
and related to this
uh as you can imagine trying to do the
intervention solely over the phone
now that it's impossible to do
face-to-face data collection has been
really challenging what's really
exciting is we had prior to covid
launched this partnership with boston
college computer science department and
tsunam vatrocia the vice provost for
design and innovation with a small
internal boston college grant to develop
a technology platform
where we could swap in the language the
graphics
to quickly adapt the manual for
different refugee groups and this was a
part of our scaling strategy and so with
covet 19
new energy really came into that process
of thinking how can we use digital
supports
for the community health worker to do
the sessions in a way that's engaging
and now we've really started to focus on
the family-facing version of the app
which would be done with the family
together i'm using a tablet at their
household rather than people on zoom
which we're still able to do sometimes
by phone sometimes by zoom but to make
it more engaging because they're getting
interrupted there's lots of kids you
know to use video to use imagery
has been a really important part of this
next phase using human center design and
co-design techniques
um
and the idea is if we create um using a
platform that could work on a smartphone
or a tablet now we have a flexible
platform as you think about the
ever-changing uh
and refugee patterns
in higher income countries where we can
adapt these interventions quickly with
new imagery
with community-based processes to think
about what's appropriate in the
intervention content and have different
versions of it done by lay workers
that could be readily scalable and so
that use of technology has been really
exciting and right now we've got a
somali bantu version and a bhutanese
version but you could see in the future
how we could have afghani congolese
venezuelan
so that's a really exciting new
development using technology um so just
to wrap up so i can open it up to
questions i hope we've been able to
convince you that promoting mental
health is about also looking to the
health of the family and it's critical
to longer term success of new americans
and investing in their human capital
that to do this is really going to take
partnerships and changing the narrative
to more of a strength-based approach
about new americans and refugees and
community-based participatory research
is a promising approach for engaging
communities it's iterative there's
continuous integration of lessons
learned but it also helps us to attend
to the concerns of the community as well
as do very fruitful interesting research
together
and ultimately to arrive at
interventions that are acceptable
sustainable
feasible and hopefully able to be scaled
so with that i'll wrap up our formal
presentation and we can open it up to
questions i did want to mention
that we are hiring uh so those of you
interested in this kind of global work
both in uh you know the united states as
well in sub-saharan africa
here's the context please be in touch
with us um we're doing this kind of work
in so many different settings and we're
just really proud of this research with
our bhutanese and somali bantu partners
a lot of references to our presentation
if you're interested as well so um
there you have it uh now we can open it
up all right
uh that that's super interesting thanks
very much teresa and everyone um the
questions i have is that i would be very
curious to see the quantitative results
especially of the new study
um and you know to to quantify the
uh in the rigorous fashion the impact of
an uh
on a certain outcomes but i would be
also i'm convinced that um the emphasis
on both the family and the community
you know i was very impressed by what
you've been saying about the
community meetings and uh and trying to
involve the in some fashion the whole
community
i i find that very interesting
and
i would like to see if possible at some
point
both the impacts on those those
mechanisms
so what is the impact of your
intervention on
on the community itself on how much
people trust each other how much they
collaborate and uh and there are a
number of quantitative measures that one
can
uh
implement and collect uh to do that
in addition to that
i would also like to understand
um
the
weather the extent to which this
community affects and these family
effects uh act as mediators
for for the final outcome from the final
mental
outcome
and finally in terms of implementation
uh
i would love to see i don't know whether
there is power enough in the experiments
that you're running but uh something
that would be very interesting would be
to
especially with covert especially with
thinking of
how to run interventions with a limited
amount of resources would be really
interesting to think of
what aspect of the interventions are
crucial
are key to obtain a certain effects and
therefore
but in order to do that you would have
to have a variability within the
treatment groups
in those aspects
and sometimes you know you can make
a virtue of some problems
so suppose they have some
locations where the
people running are higher quality
whatever or you can randomly variate
some aspects of the interventions and
let's stop here
yeah no uh
these are all really important
methodological issues and it's exactly
why buwan is now applying to phd
programs to help contribute um to all
the richness that is still to be done
just to give some brief answers on the
methods and then buwan should talk about
the lived experience of the community
because he's certainly more expert than
i am but i absolutely agree with you
that there are designs and measures that
we can do at the community level in my
public health training at the harvard
school public health i worked with tony
earls on his project on human
development chicago neighborhoods which
is famous for its paper and science on
the measurement of collective efficacy
um which is a synthesis of informal
social control and social cohesion and
they had an independent neighborhood
assessment of that so it wasn't just
self-reported by people in the
intervention but you go door-to-door and
get a measure of it by neighborhood and
wouldn't that be amazing if we'd be able
to scale this to collect that kind of
community data with these kind of
processes some communities randomly
being allocated to be in this kind of
cbpr work and others to be usual care
um control sites that would be
fascinating and then when it comes to
the community effects and family effects
acting as mediators absolutely and
that's sort of in our conceptual model
right that we really see if we can shift
the family dynamics and that also means
their navigation of community
relationships and resources we believe
by theory that we can improve the mental
health of the kids and see better family
functioning and you know in 80 family
pilot there's not much we can do in the
150 family
data once we get that complete we're
about halfway there maybe getting beyond
halfway there now
but kova to slowed us down we'll have a
little more statistical power to do
those sorts of mediational analyses and
then
lastly when it comes to thinking about
dismantling studies or isolating the
active ingredients this is certainly a
topic of great interest in
evidence-based behavioral interventions
of many sorts mental health early
childhood development how do we make
sure we're doing the the most powerful
things and like removing the noise and
then also thinking about what works for
whom under what circumstances so what
modules given a family's makeup really
need to happen with this family and we
do a lot of this we have supplemental
modules that we may swap in
an additional referrals that we often
are making along the process with the
family and substance abuse being a
common theme that we've had to do a lot
of referrals or treatment for
post-traumatic stress disorder or
depression in the in the caregivers um
or housing and security food insecurity
legal issues um
and so it would be very interesting to
iterate
those ingredients and
use dismantling studies on
implementation science we do have very
interesting data that you may be
interested in
on fidelity and so our implementation
science strategy that we're testing um
builds off of some of the work we were
doing in sierra leone actually using
collaborative teams inter-agency
collaborative teams to enhance the
fidelity of the intervention done by the
home visitors now we have a small
because we have two communities our seed
team of experts
are people who've done the intervention
before and they know it very well
they've been through it with many
families and they then serve as an
expert guide
knowing the culture and the language to
listen with permission we get permission
to audio tape their sessions and we have
the home visitor ask permission in the
family saying i'm learning to do this do
i have your permission to audiotape um
so that an expert in the intervention
can hear how i'm doing and give me
feedback so i can do my best practice
with you and you know oftentimes um
families are very open to that you know
the recorder becomes a non-issue when
you're really focused on the work with
the family and then they're doing
targeted supervision so they may come
back and say look you're doing a great
job on this and that but here's some
areas i want to focus with you to
prepare for your next session and using
that collaborative team approach
we have a sea team of experts and we're
really looking at fidelity and we
actually have them score a checklist a
fidelity checklist both about the
session specific elements and the
cross-cutting um just performance on
rapport on relationship on quality um
that we have data on
um so i'm watching the time i know we
don't have a lot of time teresa and i
want buwan to be able to speak about
just the impact on the community
sure uh thank you for the question and i
know it's um
we have uh that's what we have talked in
our our values about the cbpr approach
and i mean um it is it takes a lot of
preparation and time to invest in a
community which has a low literacy rate
but again
i can
give my own example that
i had no prior idea about how to
even to assess the needs of our
population of our own community i mean
engaging people like me and additionally
other non-skilled
people to be community health workers
and then
maybe
that kind of resources if we are able to
develop in the community
uh and also just to let you know that
our community is really a stratified
society we have lots of cast classes and
all kind of stratification and make sure
to engage them
um
with the different kinds of background
and those uh
so we'll be able to
check their um viewpoints and also uh
just to talk about the developing uh
building the trust which is not easy
thing to do because refugee communities
back in refugee camp have been
not treated fairly and because of the
politicians and all kind of
bad experience that they might have had
and unknown person coming from the
university and
majority of them are white and they are
coming and asking about all kind of
questions about their life background
history
given the political
uh public charges and all kind of big
things are coming it's really scary that
is the reason we need to have um real
um
we need to find out
and reach out to the community
self-help organizations faith-based
organizations to make sure that you work
with the community
members who are
well-known in their community so that
they can bring
the additional group of people and
and then we will be able to do the
research work because it's really
impossible for researchers along to
build up the strength-based
interventions
and i think uh in terms of kovid
kobit has definitely brought challenges
and
i think we really have an opportunity to
train our community members how to
utilize
first of all to train them to be a
community health workers uh to do data
collection and research minimum level of
training so that they can
have the skill for their life but in
terms of the sustainability i would like
to mention that after the research
project is done it's um again dr
bettencourt has mentioned that we have
we hope that the
community health workers services would
be believable in the future and instead
of massachusetts is really at the
forefront of the community health worker
uh work but again this is really uh we
are hopeful that we will one day be able
to
utilize the csw services not only in the
clinical setting but also in this kind
of resource settings
so
we have run out of time i'm sure that
both teresa and wuhan if you have some
more questions are happy to
pass along those and if you just join me
in thanking them for this great
presentation
thank you gohan thank you teresa thank
you thank you so much for having us this
is our great honor on a historic day
thank you everyone stay safe stay
healthy
thank you